[Applaudissements]
on faire habiller comme dans les années
collège
j'adore ça règlerait été magnifique
c'est la jauge permet vous l'attendez
tous les soirs à cédric 6r c'est devenu
un rendez vous incontournable
ces voitures savais que j'allais dire ça
parce que je lis dans vos pensées est-ce
qu'il a aujourd'hui mais c'est un peu
particulier pour moi ce soir c'est une
chronique party gop que c'est ma
centième ce soir j'aime le foot le foot
j'aime j'aime cette émission d'accord
mais tu aimes quoi vraiment c'est quoi
ton ma passion c'est vraiment leur faire
un cadeau non dévoilées voyagé mais les
voyages doit écouter battue c'est quoi
c'est pas que je t'offre en voyage c'est
vrai un séjour dans la demeure si vous
voulez partir avec cédric 6h à l'eva
d'hiver on lance un très jeune au poker
avec plage taxe isère auquel voulaient
partir en week end dans une ville
d'europe et vivre comme n'importe quel
bulletin parti allait bien dessus plates
excuses pour sa centième c'est mon
cadeau
eh ben ça fait plus rare en chine sont
parfaites pour remercier d'ailleurs pour
de me laisser venir qui fait avec vous
tous les soirs c'est cool tous les
messages que je vais avoir une belle
chronique et gratuitement on ne fait pas
la fine bouche je cours pour alors si
vous avez pris une grande décision dès
2020 une grande résolution
et quoi parce que 2020 pour vous ça rime
avec 10 20 ça va être l'année de
l'apaisement de la douceur mieux de la
fraternité j'ai remarqué ça comme ça non
mais là c'est vraiment encore plus
rarement je vous ai vu aussi sympa avec
des autres chaînes de télé ouais
franchement dès la première émission 7
cette année là en 2020 j'ai ressenti un
nouvel homme qui aurait tapé zen sur
google je suis tombé sur vous en direct
griottons propre méthode de relaxation
qui a vraiment l'air de fonctionner la
base n
[Musique]
et les grosses d'arca sur boyard landes
sur la tête de ma mère les jeux jamais
vue des jeux aussi ripoux il n'y a pas
de lumière
j'étais persuadé que ça allait super
bien et en fait voilà voilà de mer
pourquoi ils sont dans le noir mais on a
enfin le parc d'attractions ça veut dire
que c'est un truc de fou mais le monde a
vu des missions à la castaldi
le pire c'est quoi ces cas une saison de
très pur comme ça si ces services
publics qui englobe l'argent à jeter
quelques instants jouera the mask
chronicle on va jouer comme dans
l'émission et nous la seule différence
c'est qu'il y aura quelqu'un de connu
refaire intervilles sachez le encore une
fois cela une base folie parce que ça
sera pas en direct
ça va être hyper tout l'air des veaux
vaches est laissé les conquis ses fils
vo churchill dans ce canton qui obèrent
search attendent po tang qui boxera
qu'ils espèrent d'observer betting des
référés et oui cela sentirait moins
qu'attendu d'ailleurs samedi il m'arrive
un truc de ouf joran tranquillement à la
maison qui soudera compte c'est vrai je
le dis aux gens c'était tranquille tu
vois je savais pas quoi faire
il était 22 heures quand tu vois je
rentre en tilt je suis bien et où j'ai
dit je vais me reposer un peu et là mais
oui la chaîne préférée bien sûr je tombe
sur mon film préféré
rodhouse à patrick swayze set quand il
est videur de boîte de nuit olala ya que
des phrases de build et pendant deux
heures ouais même l'homme le plus fort
du monde ne peut rien faire si on lui
casse le genou old age
[Rires]
c'est le bras mais c'est channing pont
de royer plus balèze font un leader tu
changeras peut-être d'avis c'est tout
koné phrase quand as tu crois qu'il va
sortir des codes du groupe déploie ya
une meuf à omaha et c'est le seul mec
dans road hamra et regarder ce film
le mec il est dans une campagne perdue
il va s'occuper d'une boîte de nuit qui
s'appelle le doble douce le gars il
arrive et donc il est comme ça il est au
bail c'est vachement beau gosse il bouge
pas tu vois comme ça et toute la journée
il ya de la bagarre autour de miliani
comme qui pas de mine il est comme ça il
est tranquille mais ça passe t il pour
un coup de couteau cammas il va la
clinique mon frère de la compagne
et là c'est le sanguin il arrive aux
urgences déjà il est pris directement
relié la rive toi tu arrive aux urgences
puis dallaire a dit que tu pars à ce
rêve il a réuni tranquille quand aulas
serait à dreux 2010
et là mon frère ya un avion de chasse
une meuf une bombe atomique
karim c'est le médecin grâce à l'or il
vous arrive de gagner de vos bagages ya
jamais de vainqueur dans une bagarre
[Rires]
elle le regarde on dirait que c'est un
philosophe 12 tu sais toi tu dis ça le
médecin effet allé chez nous peut
dégager là c'est bon là j'ai c'est que
ces conneries et là après le 9 il mais
qui paie chollat médecin parce que la
médecin il lui dit je travaille 2012
c'est le seul gars aussi d'être anti mon
frère le médecin à la meuf mon frère
c'est un avion atomique
elle est déjà elle est célibataire elle
est médecin célibataire et qu'est ce
qu'elle fait le lendemain à l'arrivée
deux belles douce tranquille une petite
escapade et des canaris vont faire des
lois il en train de mettre une tanière
avec il est tout à la main et l'amapa
plutôt un confrère pécho la meuf tout
sable c'est le seul mec pour s'entraîner
à la bagarre s'est pas il va se bat avec
d'autres comme il est toute la journée
dans les bois et les commerçants
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
rien de mieux ouais j'adore l'arrivée de
videur de boîte de nuit
franchement on a une heure vous faire
des extraits du sarc du poète disparu a
bien sûr tous les cinémas de china
beaucoup de choses mais c'est vrai qu'à
l'horizon bleu morini-bosc elle sait
tout faire elle s'est levée la jambe à
plus de trois mètres de haut elle dort
dix minutes par nuit et surtout elle
fait pas d'un côté avec alain deux fois
par semaine à narita ça veut dire
qu'elle fait l'amour voilà le fait comme
ça l'oci a enfilé go on imagine alors
lundi elle a ajouté une nouvelle corde à
son silex en faisant une imitation
extraordinaire d'une copine avec qui
elle sort soit en boîte de nuit
geneviève de fontenay est tellement doué
en imitation comme production afin
d'essayer de produire son premier
spectacle regarder ça s'appelle les voix
de l'au delà
ah ouais voici la bande annonce du
premier one woman show de celle qu'on
appelle désormais isabelle dicaire
isabelle dicaire c'est plus de 3000
imitation de napoléon bonaparte à cyril
hanouna isabelle dicaire c'est aussi le
sosie officiel de geneviève de fontenay
et bonbons bio kevin est pas mis un
maillot de bain c'est of troy le mag une
bonne miss france cette année ces jeunes
ne font des quais chez le dentiste
découvrez limitation saisissante de
jean-marie le pen
[Rires]
isabelle huppert campe un père fouras
criant de vérité et le coût du spectacle
patrick sébastien au cutter au séchage
c'est génial et morue des sardines pour
le roi de la mise en boîte la limitation
de la performance vocale c les textes
qui fait exceptionnel or justement
parlant d'imitation vendredi il y aura
la première de la grosse rigolade je
vous dis on a tourné hier un casting
exceptionnel ce sera en prime time sur
s'est vite regardez j'ai un premier
extrait vous montrer parce qu'on a fait
de l'innovation la cool le bazar veut
pas de moi tu rêve depuis longtemps une
opa hostile il a déjà envahi l'écran
quoi
mais chantal voulons faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
hu
je te jure je me suis retourné
non mais je me suis dit ça et là
casty aidera gad elmaleh philippe
lachaux philippe lellouche has chantal
ladesou liane foly
j'ai même plus qu'il y avait laurent
madeline rhétorique clara morgane et
voilà un casting joue et c'est ludivine
à natori
oui oui c'est bien sûr pas de match et
de l'armée il valait mathieu que vous
d'après avec moi lundi tient dans ta
gueule
[Applaudissements]
j'invite lundi un cas sting de ouf pour
la prochaine aussi série faisait votre
propre façon de présenter vos émissions
et votre propre façon de vous habiller
mais surtout c'est votre propre langage
c'est incroyable vous avez un mélange de
verlan de tunisiens et de langage de
quartier des lilas c'est un mélange de
tout alors quelques foyers des phrases
qui sont assez compliquées commandes
parce qu'il faut que notre cerveau
arrive à tout mettre dans l'ordre ça qui
est dur stéphane bern parce que quand
ils regardent tpm pays l'objet
d'embaucher un traducteur regarde un
exemple de phrases où on rigole même si
on ne comprend pas tous les termes mais
voilà le plus rage sera dans les cafés
70 avec un coeur et il faudra vous
expliquer clairement ce que je
comprenais pas
tommy et tout est comme ça et tout
d'abord une petite gbagbo avant que la
taille valeur sûre vous excusez moi si
j'ai pas compris que des kamas et
regarde d'abord bonjour contre nature
il faut pas confondre ce qu'il faudrait
tout
lisa tu suis ma chérie oui j'ai plein
apprentissage est là tu comprends que tu
as tout compris
oui bien c'est bien sur wii vous devenir
latin mec comme ça dans les mystères de
l'amour sans rigoler ça serait génial si
tu veux on peut tout près derrière te
prêter quelqu'un je peux faire et nains
moi j'aimerais beaucoup faire une
apparition dans les mystères de l'amour
un doigt la terreur dans ses rues et tu
vas voir jean luc azoulay
il a un très joli humaniste tout à
l'heure bientôt tu vas pas être voilà il
vaudrait jean louis aubert tout cas dans
les mystères de l'amour bientôt il fera
le mystère autre chose alors avant
d'arriver dans votre émission les
chroniqueurs il était reporter de guerre
présentateur de jt ou écrivain c'est le
bout de trois émissions sais pas
pourquoi ils brillent ils deviennent
tous complètement barjo c'est 4 celui
qu'on confond souvent dans la rue avec
casimir tellement il est orange
bernard montiel ces doses enregisté a
mais là ils épient les oranje alors pas
du tout n'est dans un suv stingers jégo
bruit chez orange
non c'est vrai que c'est ce que je t'ai
dit pendant la pub genish espoir 4
j'espère que j'ai aussi beaucoup toi
plus tard gentil way home on ajustera
ajouté mais bernard sur tf1 n'y avait
pas un pli qui dépassait il présentait
des vidéos de chats qui va du languedoc
est aujourd'hui passée soirée à jouer au
scrabble avec brigitte maquereau ou à
regarder ses prestations inoubliables
dans la série sous le point soleil tu
l'aidés clarifié nous transforme il
évacue sa frustration les rires archi
les collègues les invités rien à [ __ ]
en 60 ans de carrière je vais y arriver
vous avez connu bernard montiel l'ange
dans tp vous a découvert bernard le
démon qu'elle deux minutes ça va
[Rires]
exner mandela je tenais à 12h ce pas
mettez lui quelque chose mais tu lui as
tu veux quoi guronsan non mais je suis
relax max will et emma le dis un truc tu
n'as rien à taper croire oui c'est vrai
ouais alors bernard il n'avait jamais
dit un gros mot de sa vie avant tmp est
maintenant c'est jean marie bigard le
garde chasse au sort mais il vaut toutes
les choses graves
et maintenant tellement qu'il est devenu
ouf
il a même pas peur d'attaquer car
risquant même tamazighte pas ramassées
au site d'infos là qu'en tant que je
vais céder ma place à vidéo gag puisque
j'étais viré il a dit c'est ta gueule
les maquilleuses tout ça tu fais du
cinéma au ralenti dans la salle de
sports d'hiver
encore plus grand que brice bernard
jeanne calment fabiano coeur
c'est tout
non
il a dit avec ta grand mère s'est passé
c'est un des meilleurs délais il a dit
la bêta d'euros mais sortir votre
préféré il devient alors qu'on finir
mais revenir demain vous saurez qui sera
le premier temps baba d'année 2010 un
suspense incroyable
en attendant je sais que les
chroniqueurs actif vous en mettre plein
la race là c'est vrai j'ai remarqué
c'est un peu leur contre attaque au
tabac j'étais très choquée de voir votre
mii le plus fidèle vous allez voir ils
se permettent de vous cacher vous allez
voir je vous laisse découvrir ce que
vous verrez chaque mercredi une nouvelle
édition du mama clash
[Musique]
moi moi c'était ma technique c'est quoi
pour le passage à louer au nouvel an je
dis bien on s'embrasse à 23h58 jusqu'à
minuit comme ça ça fait jour on a été
pendant un saut un ensemble et non mais
un truc ringard comme ça ça marche que
dans les années 80
[Applaudissements]
racine carrée alors la santé à 49 oui
c'est cette voie là dans ton cul votre
modère le dos au jeu les desmarais de
matthieu delormeau way d'aller faire un
chiffre de 0 à 5 16 comme ça à chaque
doigt sa peau mais il ya les gens aussi
qui change souvent de coiffure ailleurs
un pc
malheureusement ça ça peut on peut se
dire bah là personnelle passée sûre
d'elle on peut vous prendre en exemple
où il prépare très bien qu'ils s'aiment
qui se fait des bisous dans la glace et
la conclusion de tout ça ouais c'est
peut-être qu'il ya un manque de
confiance en vous bravo et sa tête le
travail et jean michel tu peux lui
répondre ce play back in merde
[Rires]
ch
[Applaudissements]